[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 europe une
émission enregistrée une nouvelle fois
au parlement européen ce mois ci nous
sommes à bruxelles et contrairement aux
numéros précédents et pour conclure
cette saison européenne deux invités en
plateau pas d'euro députés franciliens
ce mois ci mais des experts des
questions européennes
charles massi marcy pardon responsable
du bureau de bruxelles et de la
fondation robert schuman
vous publiez des études sur l'union
européenne et jean sébastien lefebvre
chef du bureau de bruxelles du journal
contexte spécialisés notamment sur les
questions de politique européenne
bonsoir messieurs bon ça cette émission
je le disais est un peu spéciale du coup
c'est la dernière du 7-8 europe pour tv
78 on va tenter d'éclairer les électeurs
de demain décrypter cette europe mais
surtout les élections européennes elles
sont prévues pour mai 2019 et pourrait
déboucher sur une recomposition
d'ampleur du paysage politique
europhile et aux sceptiques en sont
convaincus
[Musique]
mais avant de rentrer dans le vif du
sujet nous sommes allés à la rencontre
des yvelinois pour recueillir leurs
questions et leurs impressions sur ses
futures élections
on tentera ensuite de répondre à leurs
questions les écoutes
c'est vrai que leur va pas donc à les
entendre ils vont tout faire ils vont
tout casser mais finalement
là on voit pas le bout quoi eh bien je
comme je ne les connais pas j'aimerais
bien savoir ce qu'ils font voilà c'est
tout ce que je vais dire du mal mais le
maquereau amplement pouvoir qui devait
tout tout bouleverser on s'aperçoit en
fait que c'est une marionnette comme les
autres quoi bola le passé les comptes en
plus il est jeune à quoi sert à un
député européen qu'est-ce que quelles
sont ses fonctions précisément tous les
jours et puis globalement dans l'année
caisse qui gère en fait j'aimerais
savoir en quoi l'assemblée européenne
peut avoir une influence sur la
politique de migration à ce que chacun
fait ce qu'il veut ou à ce que l'europe
c'est un ensemble
voilà le sujet que souhaitez-vous au
niveau d'écologie parce qu'aujourd'hui
donc ce que l'on voit c'est qu'on
construit on construit à tour de bras ce
surtout en région parisienne est bon on
laisse la nature se dégrader et rien ne
se passe la question qui se pose
actuellement ses skis j'écoute le peuple
sujet de l'immigration sujet de
l'environnement
bon on sait pas trop ce qui se passe
alors beaucoup d'interrogations
visiblement quand il s'agit de l'union
européenne beaucoup de questions se
posent d'interrogation il faut planter
le décor déjà et donner les clés aux
futurs électeurs nous rappelez peut-être
le rôle d'un eurodéputé est il le même
qu'à un député français à l'assemblée
nationale sur de marcy est-ce qu'on peut
comparer ces deux rôles là malheureux de
l'eurodéputé c'est de voter les lois qui
sont proposées par la commission
européenne et qui sont ensuite discutées
avec le conseil qui représente les états
membres les capitales et donc le député
les étudient leurs gardes en fonction de
sa force politique en fonction aussi
quelque part de sa nationalité de son
côté régional de sa thématique et ce qui
va siéger en commission en charge des
questions agricoles ou des questions de
marché intérieur est donc ce mélange ses
différentes casquettes qui fait qu'à la
fin il doit lever le pouce pour dire oui
je soutiens tels articles tels
amendements tel texte de loi proposé par
la commission au contraire je vote
contre at-il assez de pouvoir cet
eurodéputé jean sébastien lefebvre c'est
parfois une critique qu'on peut entendre
le manque de démocratie
dans les institutions européennes at-il
assez de pouvoir aujourd'hui
ça dépend sur quel sujet sur certains
sujets un député européen a beaucoup
plus de pouvoirs et de marges de
manoeuvre car députés français par
exemple quand il s'agit de faire on va
par exemple le règlement sur la
protection des données personnelles
un député européen a beaucoup de pouvoir
puisque il doit approuver le texte et
être d'accord avec donc le conseil des
ministres de l'ue sur tout ce qui est en
vironnement aussi ils ont beaucoup de
pouvoir parce que beaucoup de
compétences sont à bruxelles on pareil
c'est de la co décision ils doivent être
d'accord pour ça puisse être approuvé
al'inverse par exemple sur la zone euro
ils ont très peu de pouvoir puisque la
zone euro et avant tout géré par les
gouvernements directement quand ils se
réunissent en sommet européen avec les
dirigeants et c'est donc sur ce sujet
moins de pouvoir mais sur plein de
choses qui sont très importantes pour la
vie quotidienne sur l'agriculture par
exemple on va réformer la politique
agricole commune dans les prochaines
années
le parlement européen à la moitié du
pouvoir puisqu'il doit de codécider le
texte alors petite précision aujourd'hui
751 députés au parlement européen en
2019 ce sera 705 du fait d'une brique
site - d'eurodéputés pourtant la france
n en récupèrent en récupère 5 comme on
explique cette balance un peu paradoxal
alors en fait dans la précédente
répartition la france avait 74 députés
et là on remarquer qu'en fait un député
européen français représentait beaucoup
trop de citoyens par rapport à la
population que dans d'autres pays
donc du coup il y avait quand même un
déséquilibre même si c'est jamais temps
de députés pour tant de citoyens parce
que sinon certains états seraient très
peu représentées comme les plus petits
le luxembourg par exemple
donc du coup il s'agissait quand même de
rétablir un peu l'équilibré pour la
france du coup il a accordé cinq sièges
supplémentaires donc dans la prochaine
législature auprès de 1019 sur à 79
députés français
ce qui fait de la france la deuxième
délégation toujours après l'allemagne
qui sera toujours je crois un 16 députés
voilà ce qui veut dire que la france va
avoir plus de poids politique au sein du
prochain parlement européen la voix de
la france va se faire plus entendre dans
les décisions futures à venir oui mais
non ou non mais oui ça va dépendre au
sein des groupes politiques qui les
eurodéputés siège par force politique
droite gauche vers les extrêmes les non
inscrits qui est une non forces
politiques
hélas ce qui est intéressant c'est par
cet effet de levier avec beaucoup de
députés concentré dans ces groupes parce
que c'est eux qui vont décider de
l'agenda de la répartition des postes à
la responsabilité qui va être présentes
commission qui va obtenir le rapport que
tout le monde veut qui au contraire
obtenir le rapport que personne ne veut
et donc il a il ya un poids qui est
fondamentale au sein des groupes ils
vont faire ensuite une sorte de
coalition alors un peu la grande
coalition au niveau allemand ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui avec la droite et la gauche
qui s'associent pour soutenir les textes
proposés par la commission européenne et
donc si vous avez beaucoup députés mais
qui sont éparpillés collectivement votre
point est assez faible
si vous avez des députés qui sont assez
concentrés là collectivement votre poids
et renforcer une nouvelle question cette
fois-ci d'un élu local
un élu de maurepas bonjour je me cherche
à pas je suis élu de maurepas et je suis
élu communautaire à saint quentin en
yvelines
moi quand j'ai une question relatifs à
la france que je veux m'adresser à mon
député je sais à qui m'adresser
par contre quand j'ai une question sur
l'europe je ne sais pas à qui m'adresser
à quel député européen m'adresser je ne
sais même plus qui sont les députés
européens élus dans les yvelines
alors sept élus regrettent que les
eurodéputés en ile-de-france fois soit
méconnu précisons que ça ne va pas
forcément s'arranger pour les prochaines
élections puisque c'est fini en gros les
circonscriptions
une seule liste par parti pour pour
toute la france avait éloigné du coup
les lecteurs encore de des eurodéputés c
une des questions qui ont été soulevées
au long de cette réforme en france il
faut savoir que c'est vraiment chaque
pays qui décide comment il va pas le
même fonctionnement nous on n'a pas le
même fonctionnement est une liste
nationale ou des listes régionales
chaque pays adapte en fonction de ses
particularismes alors le plus grand
risque je dirais c'est effectivement un
éloignement mais un événement dans le
sens où si dans la constitution des
listes parce que le fait qu'avant les
listes étaient régional sa force elle
est partie quand même à mettre des
personnalités régionales denrées chaque
circonscription pour pouvoir récolter
des voix et c'est là comme c'est au
niveau national cette obligation est un
peu les plus nécessaires et la crainte
de certains élus aujourd'hui au
parlement européen c'est de se dire oui
moi je suis avant tout un élu régional
plus qu'un élu national et du coup je
risque de disparaître de la prochaine
liste commune qui va être fait
donc oui potentiellement après est-ce
que même aujourd'hui que les listes
régionales
on a du mal et sont décédés européens ou
autres personnes
charles de marcy votre avis là-dessus
beaucoup emmanuel macron a fait ce pari
des listes d'une liste nationale
il estime que justement il faut
renforcer ce que j'exprime tout à
l'heure ce côté des très forts au niveau
des groupes politiques ici est donc dans
ce critère-là cette logique là elle est
certes nationale
liel pas ce qu'il va dire voilà si vous
avez voté pour malisse ou la lisent la
droite ou de la gauche
ensuite on sait où est ce qu'ils vont
siéger ici donc il y aura quelque part
ce renforcement et éviter d'avoir cette
disparité
le second élément c'est pour nous il y
avait pas de forces politiques
existantes
il n'a pas aujourd'hui d'eurodéputés
c'était aussi compliqué pour lui d'aller
chercher au niveau régional parce qu'ils
mangent gens connus aussi les profils
personnels s'en verra dans une suite
mais même dans une suite logique
politique
si vous n'avez pas cet échelon local
puisque c'est un parti qui a moins de
deux ans quelque part il était aussi
embarrassé donc là il ya une logique
politique tout à fait rationnelle de la
part du président et du gouvernement en
place et puis un troisième élément sur
le volet de communication risque on les
connaît pas assez mais là c'est assez
particulier parce que par exemple les
français sont friands de politique elle
avait 200 à 300 émissions politiques par
mois en france
on est en train d'en faire une donc vous
en avez tout le temps sauf que c'est la
prime est à celui qui va être basé à
paris sauf que si vous voulez poser à
bruxelles ou à strasbourg il faut être
présent à bruxelles ou à strasbourg on
bravo à vous parce que vous venez faire
votre émission ici mais ce n'est pas le
cas des 199 autres émissions quant à
chaque mois donc vous avez aussi ici
cette ambiguïté entre eux on veut les
connaître mais si on les fait se
déplacer à paris trois fois par semaine
bah ils font pas le boulot ici donc est
ce que vous voulez mieux les connaître
ou qu'il fasse mais leur boulot on verra
ça en mai prochain truc taha lors des
prochaines élections à vendre avant de
poursuivre cette émission retour en
arrière avec un peu d'histoire tous les
mois tv 78 vous fait découvrir le
parcours des hommes et femmes politiques
qui font le vieux continent aujourd'hui
retour sur le parcours d'un ancien
président du parlement européen
justement l'allemand martin schulz élus
de 2012 à 2016
son parcours avec philippe le guen
directeur de l'associer à l'association
j'emmenais de bazoches sur guyonne dans
les yvelines
[Musique]
oui alors martin schulz c'est aussi un
personnage qui a eu un parcours assez
original puisque
il est sorti du système scolaire ce sens
en bacs et il a fait une formation
professionnels de libraires et donc il a
au début de sa villa était libraire et
donc il a un coût d'ailleurs toujours
très prononcé pour les livres et
parallèlement il s'est engagé dans le
spd donc local de sa région de rhénanie
du nez il est originaire et il est donc
le spd le parti social démocrate
allemand équivalent à peu le parti
socialiste en france et il a gravi aussi
les échelons mais assez vite puisqu'il
est devenu d'abord conseiller municipal
de sa ville et ensuite il est devenu
maire à ces jeunes il a été même le
premier bourgmestre de le plus jeune de
deux d'allemagne ce qui est ensuite la
propulser un petit peu donc au niveau de
son parti il s'est fait remarquer il a
été ensuite candidats pour pour les
élections européennes est très tôt il
s'est trouvé donc député européen il a
fait finalement toute sa carrière
politique en tant que député européen je
crois que martin schulz aidé avant tout
un rhénan et vous savez que l'aréna li
en allemagne c'est quand même
la mentalité particulière c'est le rhin
le rein est un fleuve qui traverse
plusieurs pays c'est dans des
territoires de frontières c'est des
territoires qui au cours de l'histoire
on second était souvent occupés ou ont
connu des guerres ont changé de 2
possession au fil des ans et donc les
rhénans ont un intérêt particulier
sûrement pour pour si leurs voisins pour
les pays voisins peut-être plus que
d'autres régions allemandes et martin
schulz par la région d'où il vient qui
est une région proche de la belgique
donc très bien le français parlent très
bien l'anglais
effectivement mais aussi des langues
comme l'italien ou même le néerlandais
donc je crois qu'il a été très jeunes
attirés par les cultures des pays
voisins
et tout naturellement quand on est dans
ce profil là et qu'on est un homme
politique eh bien on s'oriente vers la
politique européenne via la prise de
décision au niveau européen et je crois
que au fil des années en plus il a il a
eu un goût très prononcé pour cela il a
été très très actif au parlement
européen puisqu'il en a même était
devenu ensuite le président et je crois
que d'ailleurs que son mandat de
président a marqué l'institution dans le
dans le sens des réformes qui ont été
entreprises à cette époque
[Musique]
martin schulz candidat malheureux aux
dernières élections législatives en
allemagne at il été un bon président du
parlement européen entre 2012 et 2016 at
il permis à cette institution de se
faire plus connaître auprès des auprès
des européens
jean sébastien lefebvre je pense que oui
il est lavé 7 cette actualité de
vraiment vouloir faire exister le
parlement européen dans le jeu politique
à bruxelles est aussi dans les opinions
publiques par exemple en france on a pu
le voir à l'émission le petit journal
ouais ce qui était une première pour un
président du parlement européen après à
bruxelles même il laisse un avis mitigé
parce que c'était à la fois quelqu'un
qui était capable de construire des
choses mais qui avait parfois une
manière une pratique un peu brutale du
pouvoir il malmené ccc députés de gauche
possibilité 107 socialistes étaient
critiqués parce qu'on disait mais ils
ont parfois il est plus à droite que que
le centre les libéraux etc
donc c'était en est à présent du
parlement européen important
maintenant on verra comment son héritage
vie ce que ça fait juste un an et demi
deux ans qu'il est parti donc faut
encore un peu tôt pour juger
aujourd'hui c'est l'italien alors je ne
sais pas si je vais bien prononcé son
nom antonio tajani qui l'a remplacé par
ailleurs alors vous faites un mot
visible principe du coup qu'en est il de
son successeur arrive t'il lui aussi a
marqué de son empreinte le parlement
européen c'est là où on voit l'europe
c'est qu'on a deux profils qui répondent
totalement à leur identité nationale
transposé au niveau européen martin
schulz est aussi l'homme de la grande
coalition ici au parlement avec la
commission qui a bénéficié des nouveaux
pouvoirs octroyés au parlement européen
avec le traité de lisbonne en 2009
kiwi comme jean-sébastien le site ait
essayé de beaucoup communiquer un vrai
talent d'ailleurs linguistiques anglais
français superbe et puis allemand
antonio tajani un très bon français sont
anglais et plus bruxellois donc une
vision un peu différente
et puis aussi une volonté d'être présent
partout un petit peu à la politique
italienne donc il sert beaucoup de mains
mais il va moins se projeter sur le côté
opinion publique et donc là je crois que
c'est assez caractéristique de ces
différentes d'approché et puis cette
volonté pour martin schulz vraiment
d'être collé à la proche de la
commission avec cette grande de
coalition ce qui n'a pas été tout près
par ses successeurs
alors quand toyota gagné un peu plus
clivants est vraiment va essayer de
renforcer ce côté du ppe de la droite
européenne ok c'est pas les mêmes
logiques politiques on va revenir au
scrutin du 2 mai prochain
plusieurs questions se posent notamment
qui sortira vainqueur évidemment on n'a
pas la réponse aujourd'hui la droite une
nouvelle fois le pve emmanuel macron et
éventuellement son mouvement qui
pourrait chambouler la donne politique
est ce que les socialistes vont-ils
complètement disparaître du parlement
européen les eurosceptiques vont-ils se
renforcer une nouvelle fois comme
beaucoup la non scission en europe
beaucoup de questions donc quels sont
les principaux enjeux de ce scrutin
selon vous si on peut résumer ce en
quelques phrases en quelques quelques
problématiques
alors ce qu'il faut voir c'est que le
parlement européen fonctionne sur un
principe proportionnelle serre qui s'il
n'y a pas de groupe majoritaire à lui
tout seul donc la question c'est une
fois qu'on aura les gens vont voter
c'est comment on pourra former des
majorités quand il faudra voter un texte
aujourd'hui pour former une majorité il
vous faut entre deux et trois groupes au
minimum pour faire approuver quelque
chose la question demain c est ce qui ne
fera pas 4 ou 5 du fait d'un éclatement
plus grand des voix parce qu'il faut
voir c'est que peut-être qu'en france ça
serait manuel macron qui va gagner les
élections européennes
ce sera ma chère renforcé sera pas
forcément le cas partout et normalement
ça pour ça devrait être parti populaire
européen donc la droite les républicains
qui sera toujours le plus gros partis au
parlement européen mais moins important
on estime qu'ils pourraient tomber sous
200 sièges donc 200 sur 705 ce qui fait
qu'il va falloir trouver manière de
gouverner parce qu'en plus le problème
sera l'augmentation probable du nombre
de sièges pour les eurosceptiques ou
carrément europhobe pour les plus pour
les plus extrêmes et le problème avec
ces partis c'est que souvent ils ne
jouent pas le jeu complet de la
démocratie parlementaire ça veut dire
que même si parfois ils pourraient être
d'accord avec my jurent ils refusent de
la beauté par principe parce qu'ils
disent que de toute façon c'est pas bien
l'europe où ça devrait être gérée au
niveau national et c'est donc c'est ça
la question c'est est ce qu'on aura un
parlement européen qui pourra voter les
textes cohérent et sans troller diluée
non plus parce que si vous êtes obligés
de chercher des soutiens très à gauche
et très adroites à la fin vous avez
quelque chose qui veut plus rien dire
visiblement le ppe pourrait rester le
premier parti au parlement européen est
ce que ça veut dire que emmanuel macron
ne va pas réussir à faire la même chose
sur le vieux continent comme comme en
france il a pu le faire en 2017
mais ce que l'europe et la france en
grand politiquement aujourd'hui je
dirais non
le système est pas le même il faudra
trouver des coalitions personne ne peut
arriver à gérer tout seul c'est un
système très différent du parlement
français finalement où il ya majoritaire
qui votent
on va dire presque tout seul ici c'est
un modèle allemand ont fait qui
s'applique aux paramètres de coalition
donc vous avez ça d'ailleurs dans les
trois quarts des des systèmes politiques
si nous faisions face au stade français
les différends avec le poids du présent
la république - du premier donc c'est
assez particulier donc on veut pas le
dupliquer complètement à bruxelles ce
qui fait que la logique française de
disruption total est pas là même où si
c'est la même
elle conduira pas mettre en avant des
forces pro-européennes mais plutôt des
forces eurosceptiques ou europhobes donc
il ya des éléments qui peuvent être
comparés le rejet par exemple des élites
dits traditionnels
ça se joue ça s'est joué au niveau
français se joue quasiment partout
aujourd'hui en europe si on regarde les
deux derniers scrutins au niveau
européen
donc là il peut y avoir une crainte mais
ceux là vont pas se rejoindre vu sur le
rejet de la vieille politique
donc c'est là où il falloir regarder
sait quels sont les enjeux réellement
européen sur quoi est ce qu'on veut
pousser le côté l'europe qui protège
pour simplifier tout le monde est plus
ou moins d'accord même si vous avez par
exemple des partis comme le front
national qui votent pas et s'était
soulevée par jean-sébastien qui votent
pas quand on vote sur schengen sur quoi
que ce soit comme s'est proposée par la
commission et que c'est l'union
européenne on vote contre et compris des
choses pour lesquelles eux essayent de
plaider au niveau national donc vous
êtes anglais vite et il faudrait en
sortir
et puis si vous avez l'ensemble des deux
des eurosceptiques pas les europhobes
refah veulent tout détruire les
eurosceptiques veulent en fait le statu
quo et mais c'est un petit peu le
transfert de compétences vont jouer
contre les pro européens même si on voit
et compris par exemple si la république
et en france aujourd'hui que le côté pro
européen est à mettre avec deux trois ou
quatre guillemets parce que vous avez
cette distinction est ce qu'on va vers
vraiment ce côté macron qui a fait
campagne au niveau européen qui a mis ça
comme un élément de clivage avec les
autres forces politiques
et ça a fonctionné est-ce que ce sera
suffisant pour gagner les prochaines
élections européennes compliqué donc là
je crois qu'il faudra parler du contenu
du programme et pas seulement du slogan
ballons bleus et drapeaux et justement
sur le programme un mot rapidement avant
notre dernier module comparaison avec
les autres pays européens
je voulais savoir selon le dernier
sondage eurobaromètre la lutte contre le
chômage des jeunes et le terrorisme avec
l'immigration sur les trois thèmes de
campagne majeure pour ces élections est
d'accord avec ça c'est là dessus que ça
va se jouer
c'est probable
on voit que le grand slogan comme disait
charles ça va être l'europe qui protège
alors après on ne peut mettre un peu ce
qu'on veut de dents est ce que c'est du
social est ce que ces deux mais ça va
laisser des traces du kiwi avec tout ce
qui s'est passé ces dernières années les
craintes pour l'avenir la guerre
commerciale avec trump les relations
tendues avec la russie ou autre en
général ça va être la question de voilà
comment
faire en sorte que l'union européenne
perdure et se défendre face aux
potentielles agressions extérieures
charles martin chose à rajouter sur ces
thèmes de corbère éléments auxquels
l'union européenne apporte pas de
réponse parce que les états membres ont
des visions trop différente ça va être
le volet migratoire pas la question des
réfugiés le volet migratoires au sens
beaucoup plus large et qui par extension
va toucher la question de la sécurité du
terrorisme bien entendu mais aussi de
l'identité et là on voit que j'ai
finalement assez anxiogène beaucoup de
feux des sujets anxiogène on parlera
moins d'erasmus on parlera moins de la
transition énergétique
ça fera partie des programmes mais ce
serait le 40e points les trois premiers
points ce sera à schengen zone euro et
comme mon faible et l'environnement sève
de bouleau
justement on en vient avec notre
rubrique et chez nos voisins ça se passe
comment intéressons-nous ce mois ci à
nos déchets en france et produit 100 111
kg de déchets ménagers par an mais que
deviennent ces déchets où on est le
recyclage en europe ont fait le point
avec olivier jeanne works à responsable
du centre europe direct à saint germain
en laye
[Musique]
le recyclage est une question qui est
important pour l'union européenne car
derrière le recyclage en fait il ya un
objectif environnemental il ya aussi un
objectif économique
la quantité de déchets ménagers produits
dépend du pays et dépend aussi du niveau
de vie du pays
si on prend quelques exemples par
exemple les danois sur les pubs leçons
les plus pollueurs avec 759 kg de
déchets ménagers produits par an et par
habitant
le moins pollueur c'est la roumanie avec
seulement 2 154 kg de déchets par an la
france elle est dans la moyenne
européenne avec en moyenne 5 111 kg de
déchets tandis que si on compare avec
notre voisin allemand
notre voisin allemand lui qui est à 6
118 kg de déchets par an le taux de
recyclage dépend aussi de ce qui est
prévu dans le pays par exemple on disait
l'allemagne avec 6 118 kg de déchets et
quand même un gros pollueurs mais elle
arrive en premier dans les pays qui
recycle alors par exemple l'allemagne
réussit que le ces déchets ménagers à
plus de 66 1%
elle est suivie par l'autriche à 56 9%
et la slovénie à 54 1%
la france elle est en cinquième ou
sixième position avec 35 9 % de
recyclage la valorisation des déchets
correspondent concrètement en fait à la
réutilisation des déchets pour une autre
utilisation ou notamment pour la
production d'énergie par exemple en la
matière c'est l'autriche qui est
première du classement avec 175 % de
déchets compostés elle est suivie par le
danemark et les pays bas la france elle
est en sixième position avec 87 kg de
déchets compostés par an alors après on
peut toujours un peu on va dire affiner
l'analyse parce que la revalorisation
des déchets tout dépend aussi dans quel
secteur on les valorise par exemple tout
ce qui est les déchets plastiques
peuvent être utilisés que ce soit dans
l'industrie dans l'automobile dans la
construction le btp et ainsi de suite
au niveau européen on recycle 31,1 pour
déchets plastiques tandis qu'on les vals
on les valorise à hauteur de 41 6%
le choix est laissé à chaque état tout
dépend du système que les états ont mis
en place alors concernant la france
traditionnellement on était sur un
système où grosso modo on laissait les
déchets à l'air libre on les enterrer
c'est pas le ce n'est pas le parti pris
de d'autres pays européens on a par
exemple l'allemagne qui a mis en place
un système de consigne
en fait dès que vous avez des déchets
que ce soit des bouteilles en verre
usagé ou dégoûté plastique vous allez
dans n'importe quelle supérette et puis
vous les mettez dans la machine ou les
mettait dans la machine et la machine
vous donne de l'argent en retour on a
d'autres états qui eux ont décidé
concrètement d'incinérer les déchets
[Musique]
on parlait il ya quelques instants des
thématiques pour la future campagne
est-ce que vous pensez que le
développement durable est thématique sur
l'environnement vont trouver quand même
une place dans cette dans cette campagne
on sait que c'est des enjeux cruciaux
qui jeudi qui nous dépassent parfois et
qui je sais pas ce qu'ils vont trouver
une place mais elle devrait parce que
les prochains députés européens vont
devoir terminer la réforme de la
politique agricole commune qui sera mis
en place à partir de 2021
parallèlement l'effectif et polémiques
là l'écart en france tout à fait mais
qui normalement sera pas bouclé avant
les élections moi ça me paraît un peu
difficile
donc du coup la question c'est quoi la
politique agricole commune comment vous
l'articuler jurerait que le
développement durable la transition
climatique et c'est donc l'environnement
fait partie des compétences de l'union
européenne c'est c'est un gros enjeu
quand même donc ça serait quand même
dommage de fans élections européennes
sans parler de quel modèle
on voudrait avoir mais on ne se fait pas
forcément élire sur sur le développement
durable
ce ténor blême mais vous dit tout à
l'heure que les thématiques serait
probablement anxiogène et le voit il
faudra trouver aussi des thématiques
pour un agenda positif et
l'environnement l'énergie la transition
ça c'est positif ça explique comment est
ce que on va améliorer notre qualité de
l'air va lutter contre la pollution le
recyclage donc ça c'est des choses qui
sont très concrètes
votre sac bleu ou jô pour pour trier
quand vous allez à la plage vous allez
voir que des bouteilles plastiques
partout comme ans qu'on lutte contre ça
donc là vous avez aussi la possibilité
pour les forces politiques et les partis
politiques
de même des choses qui soit positive et
qui a un avantage concret directement
alors que la gouvernance de la zone euro
ça va très mal effective pour la plupart
des citoyens et puis on suivra
évidemment cette campagne sur tv 78
merci charles de marcy et chant
sébastien lefebvre d'avoir participé à
cette émission vous êtes respectivement
responsable du bureau de bruxelles de la
fondation robert schuman et chef du
bureau à bruxelles aussi du journal
contexte merci aussi
aux techniciens du parlement européen
pour pour cette émission cette émission
était la dernière de la saison mais vous
pouvez réviser cet été avec nos replay
disponible sur notre site internet tv 78
de points comme bonne fin de semaine à
tous et puis aussi bel été à tous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]